-President Biden agreed to meet
with GOP senators
at the White House after
Republicans whined
about the supposed lack
of bipartisanship
in the Democrats'
response to the crisis.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
Well, You guys remember
when everyone thought
the world would just
magically snap back to normal
once Donald Trump
was no longer president,
and people like me
would have to go back
to making fun
of the Kardashians
or the latest
fast-food shock offering?
Well, hold on to your
Bacon Club Chalupa, Kourtney,
because just
in the last few days,
hedge fund vultures have lost
billions of dollars,
thanks to Redditors
driving up the stock price
of a video game store;
anti-Semitic comments from a
far-right member of Congress
have surfaced,
claiming a California wildfire
was caused by a secret
Jewish space laser;
and former President
Donald Trump's
entire defense team
quit en masse
after he insisted
that they repeat
his deranged election fraud lies
during his impeachment trial
for --
oh, sorry, what
was he charged with, again?
-The Senate impeachment trial
of the former president
of the United States,
who has been impeached for
inciting the erection --
uh, inciting the insurrection
at the U.S. Capitol.
-Well, if that's the charge,
then I hope he doesn't...
get off.
-♪ Yeah ♪
[ Laughter ]
Look, guys,
we're gonna do it every time
someone makes that mistake.
So if you don't want
the "CSI" joke,
stop making Freudian slips,
because the first rule
of "Late Night" has always been,
"When you slips, I quips."
[ Laughter ]
When I saw that this morning,
I tried to text my wife
the "get off" joke,
but it turns out,
she has my number blocked.
So then I tried calling her,
but she claims
it came up as "scam likely."
Sure, it's an old joke,
but I'm doing my best here.
I mean, where does she...
get off?
-♪ Yeah ♪
Alright, I forced that one.
[ Laughter ]
One for you, one for me.
What? They're both for me?
[ Laughter ]
Also, is there any person
less likely
to incite an erection
than our former president?
I mean, if anything,
it's the opposite, right?
If any teenage boys ever get
called to the chalkboard
at an inopportune time,
just picture this fella,
and you'll be well in the clear
by the time you're
filling in equations.
"The New York Times" published
a definitive investigation
of the 77 days Trump spent
spreading the lie
that led to the riot,
which included
truly astonishing details
about the lengths to which
Republicans were willing to go
to indulge Trump's lies
by telling themselves
he wasn't serious.
According to the "Times,"
Mitch McConnell
"heeded misplaced assurances
from White House aides
like Jared Kushner
that Mr. Trump
would eventually
accede to reality.
The Senator was also
under a false impression
that the president
was only blustering.
West Wing officials had conveyed
the same message:
They would pursue
all potential avenues
but recognized
that they might come up short.
Mr. Trump would eventually bow
to reality and accept defeat."
Why would anyone --
anyone think Trump
would bow to reality?
The same dude who thinks
Osama bin Laden's
death was faked;
windmills cause cancer,
and Diet Coke is good for you.
Of course, McConnell
didn't actually think that.
These guys
all knew what Trump was,
and they've been
riding the wave,
hoping it wouldn't
crash on the shore,
which is apparently
what happened to Steve Bannon.
You know, "Captain Ron,"
if it was a horror movie.
"Last thing I remember is
getting drunk on a yacht,
and then, all of a sudden,
I'm looking up at a lifeguard
on the boardwalk at Rehoboth."
McConnell thought he could use
Trump's delusions
and conspiracy theories
to motivate the base
and hold on to the Senate,
and it backfired on him.
And now he wants to pretend
he had no idea
who Trump really was.
I guarantee every conversation
McConnell and Trump ever had
ended with McConnell saying,
"And if anyone asks,
Mr. President, we never met."
These guys all thought
they could harness
the forces they unleashed,
but those forces are
in no way unique to Trump.
They're at the very core
of the modern GOP --
a fact that has been illustrated
by the election of
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
who sounds like a line of active
yoga wear for crazy people,
but is actually a freshman
Congresswoman
who has suggested in the past,
among other things,
that House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
should be executed for treason;
that school shootings
were staged;
and that a wildfire
in California
was caused by a secret
Jewish space laser.
-Taylor Greene repeats
a QAnon conspiracy theory
that the fire was set by
a powerful laser from space,
triggered by
a mysterious wealthy cabal.
-She believes it was
a Jewish-funded space laser
that started the 2018 wildfire,
the worst in
California history.
-It says a lot
about these folks
that if she just said
"space laser,"
then they would have said,
"She's nuts,"
but make it
"Jewish space laser,"
and they say, "We need her
in Washington!"
These aren't
just conspiracy theories.
These are the sick delusions
of a deeply deranged person.
And yet, Republicans are either
standing firmly behind her
or just brushing her beliefs
aside
like they're some odd little
personality quirk.
-She's long embraced
conspiracy theories like QAnon,
voiced support
for executing Nancy Pelosi.
Does she -- Is she fit to serve,
and should she be
on the Education Committee?
-Well, that's --
First of all,
the people of her district
elected her,
and that should mean a lot.
-Given her history,
is she fit to serve?
-I'm not going to
answer that question
as to whether she's fit to serve
because she believes
in something
that everybody else
does not accept.
I reject that, but she's
going to stand for re-election.
I don't think we ought to
punish people
from a disciplinary standpoint,
a party standpoint,
because they think something
a little bit different.
-Hmm, a little bit different?
She's not
a little bit different.
That's how you describe
a neighbor
who has multiple garden gnomes
in her front yard.
She's a little bit different.
But if she has a snowman
with human bones for arms,
maybe cut her
a little less slack.
You might remember that Greene
has also expressed support
in the past
for the QAnon conspiracy theory,
which was also prominent
among Trump supporters
and the insurrectionists
who stormed the Capitol.
Just to give you an idea of
how unhinged this cult is,
here's a former Q follower
talking to
CNN's Anderson Cooper about it.
-Did you at the time believe
that high-level Democrats
and celebrities were
worshipping Satan,
drinking the blood of children?
-Anderson, I thought
you did that.
And I would like to apologize
for that right now.
So I apologize for thinking
that you ate babies.
-That is quite the apology to
have to make to someone's face.
Personally, I would have
just sent a Fudgie the Whale.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, we're just going to -- We
are going to put the icing on.
We did just want to double-check
what you gave us."
Also, a very, very hard apology
to accept.
I mean, definitely better that
he made the apology than not,
but how do you even
respond to that?
"Well, it means
a great deal to me
that you no longer think
that I ate more than one baby.
You're back
in the wedding party."
We're in the midst of several
unprecedented crises right now
that are causing
misery and suffering
for millions of Americans.
The previous administration
badly botched
the vaccine rollout;
poverty and child hunger
are on the rise;
millions have lost
their health insurance;
and nearly half a million people
have died.
And one of our
two major political parties
has become deeply unhinged and
detached from reality.
And now that same party --
a party that just weeks ago
tried to overthrow
a presidential election --
is demanding,
along with a compliant media,
that Democrats and
the Biden administration
work with them
on a COVID relief plan
for the sake of
so-called bipartisanship.
-I've never been
more disappointed
about an administration launch.
Not good or bad,
but indifferent.
I almost feel as though
they were teasing us
into thinking that there'd be
an effort to go bipartisan.
-You don't want bipartisanship.
You want
the patina of bipartisanship,
but you want to stick it
and ram it through.
So that's not unity.
-There's no reason
why Joe Biden
can't work with Republicans
in the Congress
for bipartisan legislation
if he's willing
to push Bernie Sanders
to the side
and work with
Republican Senators
and Republican Congressmen.
-President Biden has missed
a historic opportunity
to make good on this pledge to
be a president for all Americans
and to stand up and say
the censorship must stop,
the blacklisting must stop.
We have to listen to
and respect
all viewpoints in America.
-Ah, yes, famously bipartisan
Stephen Miller,
the guy who brought together
the alt and the right.
The only way I can picture him
reaching across the aisle
is to steal a child's dream
and eat it for demon fuel.
Man, I was hoping I'd never have
to see Stephen Miller's face
ever again, and if I did,
I just assumed he'd be
outside my balcony
in a thunderstorm,
wearing a cape.
Look, I know it's a favorite
obsession of the media,
but no one gives a [Bleep]
about bipartisanship.
People just want someone
to make their lives better.
If someone shows up
at your house
with the vaccine
and a $2,000 check,
you're not going to ask, "Wait,
is Ted Cruz cool with this?"
Bipartisanship is
a fake Beltway obsession
that actual people
do not care about.
It probably ranks lower
on voters' list of priorities
than renovating the White House
tennis pavilion.
And thank God someone
finally did that.
If not for Melania, how would
Wilbur Ross and Larry Kudlow
have played a game of doubles
against Rudy and
his dowager's hump?
Look, Republicans,
instead of whining,
you should be thankful
you get to deal with Joe Biden,
who has way more faith
in bipartisanship than I do.
That doesn't mean
he's going to do
everything you want him to do,
but it does mean he won't
spend his time in office
giving campaign rallies where he
starts "Lock him up" chants,
which, as we all know, is
the height of bipartisanship.
In fact, President Biden is
already indulging Republicans
in what seems to be a futile
and preposterous exercise.
-A group of 10 GOP lawmakers
is calling on the White House
to compromise,
urging the president to consider
more targeted relief.
-The Republican counter-offer
reduces the overall cost
to $600 billion,
down from $1.9 trillion
that the White House is seeking.
It lowers direct payments to
Americans from $1,400 to $1,000.
It doesn't include
a minimum-wage increase.
-White House press secretary
Jen Psaki released a statement,
stating that President Biden
has invited
these 10 Republican senators
to the White House
to talk about
their counter-offer.
-Republicans, what more
do you want than that?
Just the fact that he's willing
to sit down
and listen to you at all
is more than you deserve.
You know he's getting burned,
and you know
you're trying to burn him.
But he is gonna keep
holding out hope
that we can all get along.
That's who he is.
Joe's the neighbor
who returns the Frisbee
when some kids
throw it in his yard.
And then when
they throw it back,
covered in dog crap, and
laugh when he picks it up again,
he just shakes his head
and says, "I was once like you."
And then the kids yell back,
"You were nothing like us,
old man!"
And before he can answer,
they start circling him
in their Schwinns,
whooping and hollering
until he finally starts
getting flustered and yells,
"Hey, enough is enough."
And the kids yell back,
"We decide when it's enough!
This is our town now!"
So then he grabs a stick and
he jams it in the wheel
of the leader's bike,
and that kid tumbles harmlessly
into a pile of leaves,
stands up, brushes himself off,
and yells, "Well,
that wasn't very bipartisan."
Seriously, Joe, why on Earth
are you taking anything
Susan Collins says seriously?
Just send people the checks.
No one cares
if she's moderately disappointed
with the process.
Do you think,
in lieu of a $2,000 check,
voters would be just as happy
with a postcard that says,
"Rest assured that
Susan Collins' participated
in the legislative process,
was respected,
and her opinion was heard.
As a result, please accept
this $10 gift card to Subway,
applicable only
to the tuna sandwich.
'Tuna' is not
a legally binding term"?
Republicans rammed through
a $2 trillion tax cut
for the corporations
and the wealthy,
and nearly repealed Obamacare,
using the same
budget reconciliation method
they're now whining about.
Nothing they say about
compromise and bipartisanship
should be taken seriously.
They've been pulling
the same scam for years.
You know how I know?
Because Democrats have fallen
for this trap many times before,
including a certain
vice president in 2012.
-What we need is
the Republican Party.
We need leaders
that can control their party.
And I think you're gonna see
the fever break.
-Not only did the fever
not break, it got worse,
probably thanks to that secret
Jewish space laser
that invented COVID
and hacked the election,
along with Bill Gates
and Hugo Chávez.
I see you up there, Space Laser,
eating your lox,
drinking your Manischewitz.
Republicans aren't going to
suddenly become reasonable.
It didn't happen in 2012.
It's not gonna happen now.
Take a cue from incoming Senate
budget chairman Bernie Sanders,
who was asked on Sunday
about the GOP's bad-faith call
for bipartisanship, and
immediately brushed it aside.
-Is it a mistake
for Democrats to consider
abandoning bipartisanship
negotiations so soon?
-Martha, the issue is not
bipartisanship or not.
The issue is,
are we going to address
the incredible set of crises
and the pain and the anxiety
which is in this country?
You know what?
I don't care
what anybody says,
we have got to deal
with this pandemic.
-First of all, he's right.
Second, of course,
Bernie doesn't care
what anybody says.
He has the energy of a grandpa
who insists on
shoveling the sidewalk
in his bathrobe.
"Grandpa, at least
put on some pants."
"I don't care what anybody says.
I'm going out there
in my robe and my slippers,
and if anybody
has a problem with that,
then they can
talk to the mittens,
because the face
is not listening.
Not now, not ever."
People need and deserve
immediate help.
They don't have time
for Beltway games
or bad-faith whining
about bipartisanship.
You know
what's actually unifying?
Doing popular things,
like sending out checks
and rolling out vaccines
during a pandemic
and economic crash.
That would get people excited.
So excited you could be
impeached for...
-Inciting the erection.
-Oh, that's my time
on the stage.
I guess I'd better...
get off.
-♪ Yeah ♪
Forced it.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "Donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.